SARAH THOMSON: Hello, everybody.
Good morning.
My name is Sarah, and for
the last 2 and 1/2 years
I've been heading up the indie
community on Google Play,
and it's been an
awesome experience.
I started as an indie myself
well over 10 years ago,
and it's still my
favorite group of people.
I'm a little bit
biased with indies,
so you'll probably
see that come through
as I talk to these
two amazing humans.
And this morning we
talked a lot about-- we
had some great talks
run by Googlers
and some of our partners who
were talking about improving
game quality, and how
can you really maximize
your discoverability.
And we're going to
actually kick off
into a lot of different
discussions carrying on
to build on top of that.
So today I have Sam and Mike,
who are two indie developers
and publisher, who are
really experts and have seen
a lot of success around user
acquisition, which is something
that I think a lot of
indies really struggle with.
Put your hand up if you
struggle with user acquisition--
like, where to even
start, what is it.
It's super overwhelming.
And then we also have
Butterscotch Shenanigans here,
which are experts around
community-building.
So we're going to talk
about those two things.
It's going to be super exciting.
All right.
Welcome guys.
Thanks for joining us.
SAM COSTER: Thanks.
SARAH THOMSON: So maybe let's
start with some introductions.
Sam, maybe you can start.
Talk a little bit
about yourself,
your history in gaming,
about your company, so forth.
SAM COSTER: Sure.
Yeah.
So Butterscotch Shenanigans was
founded about seven years ago
by me and my two brothers.
And a family-owned business,
which is always a terrible idea
I've heard, but it's
working out pretty good.
And we've launched five games.
We started on mobile
and we've recently
gone more cross-platform,
so our games now
reach out onto other
platforms as well,
like Steam and console.
And a big part of
our strategy has
been answering the
question, once we somehow
manage to get a
player, how can we
just keep that player around?
So instead of worrying
about user acquisition
in terms of bringing
new people in, how do we
keep people with us.
And that's sort of been
what a lot of our focus
is, around community management
and that sort of thing.
MIKE GORDON: Cool.
I'm Mike.
I'm the CEO of Iron Horse Games.
There's one person at Iron
Horse Games, and that's me.
I started the company
three years ago.
Last year we did 11
million installs,
with a heavy amount
of user acquisition.
So I do a lot of
marketing myself,
a lot of creative
testing, and mostly
focus on Idle Game publishing.
That's it.
SARAH THOMSON: Cool.
So the first obvious question I
want to ask you is, why indie?
Why did you choose to
be an indie developer?
I think a lot of people
feel it's harder than ever
to be indie, especially
in mobile and increasingly
on other platforms.
Why did you choose this path?
MIKE GORDON: Sure.
I can start.
It's personal and professional.
So personally, I had worked
at Kongregate previously
and helped build up the
mobile publishing business.
We'd worked with a lot
of really big teams,
and I wanted to get more
hands-on with smaller teams
and make an impact
on their games.
And that's been personally
really satisfying.
Professionally, I
saw that there was
a big gap in the market from
a publishing perspective.
From a business
perspective, the way
that publishing typically
works if you have success
is you build on that success.
You have a game, it generates
a lot of money, you market it,
and then start hiring on a
team to help build the games
bigger, which means that
subsequent games need
to be bigger and bigger.
And that creates
a snowball effect,
and then you look
up after four years
and you're publishing
like two games a year.
I never wanted to
do that, and felt
that there was a huge
opportunity for one
and two-person teams
to really benefit
from a lot of the learnings
that the big team had
from publishing.
So that's what I set out to
do, and largely what I've done.
SARAH THOMSON: Awesome.
SAM COSTER: Yeah.
So on our end, one is that
we really like to make games.
In the past we liked
to make them fast.
That's changed a bit.
But we started out
doing game jams,
and so that sort
of creative freedom
you get from just iterating
over a weekend we basically
extended into how we
make our games generally.
So we have a really iterative
design and development cycle.
And on top of that,
the sort of new thing
that we do at our
studio is a lot
of this really interesting
web tech and web
integration with our games.
So we built our own
proprietary account
system called Bscotch
ID, which is now
transitioned into Rumpus,
which is our "powerful back
end," as we call it.
[LAUGHTER]
And what that allows
us to do is get players
into this email system, which
now we have half a million
players who have at some
point bought one of our games
who we actually have
their email address
and we send them emails
basically once a month letting
them know what's
going on at the studio
as well as essentially hyping
up whatever our new game is
or selling merch
or whatever else.
So a big part of
our learnings have
come on that side of things.
We really wanted to have
the time and the space
to explore that
whole aspect of it
and see what we could do there.
SARAH THOMSON:
That's super cool.
So Mike, I'm going to move
over to you and dive into--
you come from gaming.
You're not new to games.
But being in this space of
really being this one-man indie
sensation, what's that been
like over the last few years?
What's the learning
curve been like?
MIKE GORDON: Yeah.
So it's nice that you called me
a sensation, because it's not--
SARAH THOMSON: Yes.
You are a sensation.
You are sensational.
MIKE GORDON: Thank you.
It's been difficult and good.
I think you can
probably relate to this.
If you have any
degree of success
you start feeling a
little bit nervous
that it's going to go away.
So that's one
element that I deal
with quite a bit,
especially when we have
a successful business, is
the feeling that it's not
going to be that way forever,
so you stay really scrappy.
I think the most important
learnings of the past three
years have really been the need
to adapt and do it quickly.
When I started Iron
Horse Games, about a year
later the app store
did its redesign.
If anyone here is a
mobile game developer,
you've probably seen what
the impacts of that are.
And then also there
have been a series
of changes on Google Play where
a lot of organic installs that
used to kind of
fall from the sky
have changed how they
come into your game.
They're all still
there, you just
have to figure out a
way to unlock them.
For me it was leaning really
heavily into marketing and user
acquisition.
So when those things
happen you need to pivot,
and you need to do it
incredibly quickly,
because otherwise
you're going to wake up
and you're not going
to have a business.
I mean, if I didn't make the
changes that I made to start
marketing aggressively
last year--
and I had done zero marketing
at Iron Horse before this--
I wouldn't be here today.
Period.
The business would not exist.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah.
So building off of
that and in reference
to what we were talking
about a little bit earlier,
is that you have really taken
on head-on the concept of user
acquisition.
And how you started
from square one--
you really didn't
know much about it,
and now you've acquired this
incredible wealth of knowledge
in that space.
So how do you do
that as an indie?
Where did you even
start with that?
MIKE GORDON: Yeah.
So, credit to Kongregate
and my time there because--
well, I wasn't actively
doing marketing myself.
I was working with
that team a lot
and kind of getting an idea
of what that looked like.
For the specific way that
I started doing marketing
and started tackling
it, the first
was algorithm change
rolled through Google Play.
Some of my games lost installs
and a lot of the games
kept them.
So I looked at why the
games who still had installs
were continuing to get them.
The answer, at least
for me, was that they
had a high third-party
referral rate.
So I was getting
a lot of installs
from outside of Google Play.
I inferred that that meant
that the algorithm might
be encouraging developers
to market their games,
so I started marketing
really conservatively
to start on live games.
I'd take about 30% of
the projected net revenue
for the month, I would reinvest
that into marketing and user
acquisition through
sources that I
was confident would have
either net neutral--
so I wouldn't lose any money on
them-- or ROI positive payback.
I mean, this is
not a lot of spend.
We're talking like
$1,000 a month.
I monitor the results,
and then as that
started gaining
success and snowballing
I developed a strategy
around marketing on open beta
and then marketing during
launch, which is probably
the most important window
that you can market
your game in on Google Play.
So the first 30 days when you
release your game globally
from open beta or
pre-registration,
the paid to organic
ratios are insane.
Like, normally on a game
that's live maybe you
buy one install on Google
Play and you get one organic.
During that launch window,
you buy one install
and you get four organics.
So knowing how to
market your game
and having some experience
marketing your game
and then aggressively marketing
during that 30-day window
gives you all kinds of
benefits outside of just
you're making money.
You can also use
that information
to pitch the folks at
Google and say, look,
I've got a really good
game here and I think
you guys should support it.
SARAH THOMSON: Right.
And you just scaled from there?
MIKE GORDON: Yeah.
That's it.
I mean, on every game we start
really small in open beta.
I'm predominately
spending my budgets
on Facebook, Unity, Google
Play, AdWords, Tapjoy, and Iron
Source, and some ad action.
Those are the big six for me.
It's a mix of display
and video ads,
and then as the
game's net revenue
grows we come up with
a monthly budget,
and then we spend that
every month at either net
neutral or ROI positive.
And my games don't
have massive RPUs.
We're talking like $0.50
CPIs for Western users.
So it can be done.
I do it every day.
I did it this morning.
Yeah.
SARAH THOMSON: And just one
last question around that.
Can you tell me a
little bit about--
you referenced the fact that
things change on the store.
Right?
MIKE GORDON: Yeah.
SARAH THOMSON: The way
that games are surfaced
and what's going on behind
the curtain, so to speak,
is changing.
And that can be
really daunting, I
think, for developers of all
sizes, but especially indies.
So how has that
been to navigate?
What's sort of your
outlook on that?
MIKE GORDON: My outlook
on it is that you guys
have a business that you're
optimizing and growing.
So I don't begrudge any changes
that happen on the store
because it's something that
Google's heavily invested in,
and it's their right to do
whatever they want with it,
to grow it and change
it as they see fit.
The way I feel about it
is that it's terrifying
when users start disappearing.
But there's always a signal.
So I have a broad data set.
I'm a publisher, so I
have 15 games or more.
Whenever anything changes I
dig deep to see who the winners
and losers were
and try and come up
with a hypothesis as to
why they won or lost.
But typically
marketing has allowed
me to weather most storms.
I think if you have a consistent
stream of marketing, whatever
is happening with organic
installs on the store,
as long as it's not affecting
that first 30-day window
and it's not punishing
us on the paid
to organic ratio for live games,
you can pretty much weather it.
You just gotta get
to that point where
you're reinvesting in
marketing on a monthly basis.
SARAH THOMSON: And I want
to point out and give a plug
for Mike's talk tomorrow.
So Mike, can you give details?
If this is really
interesting to you
and you want to hear more and
some really specific examples
in Mike's talk tomorrow, where
can they join you tomorrow?
MIKE GORDON: That's
a great question.
[LAUGHTER]
It's tomorrow.
SARAH THOMSON: Somewhere.
MIKE GORDON: It's
around 2 o'clock-ish.
SARAH THOMSON: Here.
MIKE GORDON: And it's at GDC.
It's called "Scrappy Marketing."
SARAH THOMSON: OK.
MIKE GORDON: That's it.
SARAH THOMSON: That's probably
enough information for people
to--
MIKE GORDON: That's the title.
And it's a really
good presentation.
This sounds like I
haven't prepared.
I've prepared.
I just don't know the
specific [INAUDIBLE]..
SARAH THOMSON: Awesome.
OK.
Great.
MIKE GORDON: Good time.
SARAH THOMSON: So let's
jump over to Sam here.
Thanks, Mike.
So you guys have been around
for a number of years now,
and doing a pretty good job of
weathering some crazy storms
in the indie world, and
you've seen great success.
So, what's your secret?
How have you managed to do that?
SAM COSTER: So I
think it kind of
goes back to what you
were talking about
as far as the concept of how
do you build a business that
is able to weather the various
changes that are happening
literally all the time.
So while Mike's taking more
of a marketing approach,
ours has been more on
the community engagement
side of things.
So through that
newsletter system--
essentially the
first reason we built
that was because we said, OK.
We can't necessarily
always guarantee
that Google or Apple
or anybody else
is going to give us a feature.
Right?
It's never guaranteed,
and also they've
got their own stuff going on.
Maybe Super Mario Run
launches and absorbs
all of the top
spots for something,
or all sorts of games
come out and just start
absorbing all sorts
of feature spots
where usually you would
think you'd be in there.
So we said, how can we
actually robustly build
a future for
ourselves where we get
to control at least a little
bit of that launch potential,
and actually do it without
any marketing money?
So we're heavy on the tech side.
We build a lot tools
for ourselves and things
like that to really
optimize workflows
as well as to optimize things
like these sort of marketing
back channels and stuff.
So for us the answer came
in the form of building
this proprietary tech,
which really was originally
built in PHP--
like a really kind of
hideous back end system,
Which is much better now,
much more stable now.
But it allowed people to
just back up their data.
It's a Cloud save system.
Right?
And because our games
are cross-platform
that meant that if someone
played it on their tablet
on Android and then
hopped on their PC
then they could just pick up
exactly where they came from.
And we found our users
really, really liked that,
and it also gave them a reason
to give us their email address.
So the question
then is, what do you
do once you have
that email address?
For some reason
indies in particular
really love Twitter,
when Twitter has, like,
the lowest pick-up rate of
almost any communication
channel you could ever
try to broadcast on.
It's sort of like
you're just kind
of screaming into the
void a lot, with hashtags.
[LAUGHTER]
And so, I mean, we're talking
between a 15% and 40% open rate
on these emails that
we're sending to people.
We're sending them to,
like, 150,000 people.
And what we found over the
years is that everywhere we've
gone to build an
audience has always
ended up getting restricted.
So, for example, we first
built an audience on Facebook,
and then it became
quickly clear that if we
wanted to actually reach
the 20,000 people that we
had driven to that page to
like us through our games,
that we had to pay money now
to reach the audience that we
had curated there.
And on Twitter it was the same
thing, where we couldn't quite
hit our total audience pool.
And so we said, OK.
Email looks like a
good way to do this.
And for some reason it's
not a tool that indies use.
So as far as something
that's-- it's a really,
really effective tool.
And, yes, there are some
complications with something
like GDPR, but it's actually
not particularly difficult.
It seems really scary.
And it is really easy to
walk through once you get it.
So the email newsletter system.
And then on top of that,
we do a weekly podcast,
which is just us--
me and my two brothers-- just
getting a room for an hour
and basically being weirdos.
We talk about the
games industry,
we talk about the
game we're working on,
and then we answer
community questions.
And we-- depending
on the week-- will
have around between 1,500
and 2,500 listeners per week.
And if you talk about the
power of having your fan base
listen to you talk for
an hour every week--
that's something that
really can't be matched.
And cumulatively the podcast
has had over 350,000 hours
of people listening.
Right?
And so it's allowed us
to build a fan base,
even start a little tiny
mini convention of our own
in St. Lewis where we're
based in the Midwest,
that people flew from
Florida and drove from Texas
to come see us.
So it's allowed us to
do a lot of these things
that normally we would
feel very out of reach for,
and in a lot of ways weather
all these changes long
enough that we can
pivot effectively
and take advantage of whatever
the new sort of shiny thing
is that we're supposed to do.
SARAH THOMSON: So
was that intentional,
to build your fan base
around your studio brand
as opposed to--
SAM COSTER: Yes.
SARAH THOMSON: And then,
of course, it cascades down
into the gaming brands.
But was that an intentional
thing or did you just get
lucky?
SAM COSTER: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Well, do I think it's
absolutely intentional?
And definitely luck
is involved, too.
So a big part of
it was recognizing
that we were tired of--
so basically we had
launched these four games
within two years or so.
And these were smaller,
strictly mobile titles.
And doing the run-up every
single time to launch
was always so harrowing
because you're like,
are we-- we're
talking to Google.
Are we going to get
a feature in there?
Like, I don't know.
Maybe.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we don't have money to
spend on ads, so we're like--
MIKE GORDON: You and I
both know that's not how
that happened on Crashlands.
SAM COSTER: Well,
not on Crashlands.
MIKE GORDON: Am I
going to get a feature?
Yes.
SAM COSTER: Crashlands will.
[LAUGHTER]
So the previous
four, not so much.
So, yeah.
So a big part of that
then was just saying,
how can we take a single
player coming into Crashlands
or into Flop Rocket--
one of our other games--
and how can we get them
excited about the breadth
of all the rest of our games?
So all of our
games actually take
place in the same universe.
They have the same art
style across all of them,
no matter what the genre is.
And they hop around
genres all over the place,
from things that
make you want to snap
your phone in half
to Crashlands,
which is like a 60-hour RPG.
So a big part of it was,
yeah, this really intentional,
how do we get someone
to come in and then
stay with us as a team as
opposed to just saying,
I really like that game.
I've no idea who made
it and I don't care.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah.
That's awesome.
So we're almost
out of time here,
and I really want to know--
obviously you and your brothers
have a particular talent
of that kind of
community-building effort
around the podcast.
And there's charisma and
personality happening there,
and not all of us are
blessed with that.
SAM COSTER: Sure.
SARAH THOMSON: So how
can you, as a very small,
resource-limited team, build
a community in different ways?
SAM COSTER: Yeah.
I mean, honestly I think
the highest leverage
way to do it is through
something like a newsletter.
SARAH THOMSON: OK.
SAM COSTER: A lot of people--
especially if you're an indie
or you just like making games,
a lot of people are more
introverted by nature.
And I do actually consider
myself an introvert,
I'm just good at
talking when I need to.
But I think everybody
usually has the ability
to write pretty effectively.
And you should actually
develop that skill.
And that's something that you
can do sort of on your own time
without the pressure
of an instant response.
And those email newsletters
are honestly so phenomenal.
I know there's a talk
about Chris Zukowski
about this exact topic,
I think, tomorrow,
which is all about how
to build an email list
and then use it
really effectively.
And it's one of those things
that, for some reason,
people ignore.
Kind of like the user
acquisition side on indies.
And it can help
you so much, even
if it's just like 2000 people.
Or even-- like, we started
ours with 13 people.
So, you know, it
takes a little bit.
Then you go.
MIKE GORDON: Do you guys
do any incentivization
in the actual games themselves?
Do you, like, get
this cool thing--
SAM COSTER: Yeah.
That's where, essentially,
the Cloud saving--
all those additional
features come from.
And we do cross-game--
MIKE GORDON: All
packaged together.
SAM COSTER: All
We do cross-game
unlocks and stuff, too.
So if you beat a boss
in one of our games
it will unlock a quest
line in Crashlands
when you're playing, as long
as you're on the same account.
So all sorts of crazy
tech stuff like that.
MIKE GORDON: That's cool.
SARAH THOMSON: That's awesome.
So we're going to
end on that note.
Thanks, guys.
This is huge gems
of wisdom you're
able to share with
this audience.
And thank you so much.
Join Mike's talk tomorrow.
And next up we have
Serena and Moonlit
who's going to take you on
monetization adventures.
Thank you.
SAM COSTER: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
SERENA SHIH: Hi everyone.
My name is Serena, and I am a
Google Play [? BD ?] based out
of Beijing.
We do fully overseas,
so no rumors here.
Today me and my
colleague Moonlit
will be discussing on why
revenue diversification is
a must.
We'll be going over
the following agenda,
starting from why
diversification is important,
followed by how Playgendary
and Kongregate were
able to succeed with
diversifying their revenue.
And finally, we'll be focusing
on how Google products aim
to help you successfully adopt
different business strategies.
To start, why diversify?
In the last few years
we've seen [? emergences ?]
of genre-mashing titles.
For example, we have DH
games as Idle Heroes,
which combines the RPG gameplay
with Idle Clicker assets.
And we also have
Pixelberry's Choices,
which combines the player's
love of story books
with the ability to control
the overall narrative.
The genre-mashing
trend therefore
opens up more way of revenue
diversification and innovation.
Multiple genres allow for
additional business model
combinations of IAPs,
ads, and subscriptions.
In addition to
genre-mashing titles,
in the real world
when we're trying
to access a very diversified
and good stock portfolio
it's important to not place
all of your eggs in one basket.
And therefore this helps you
diminish your overall risk.
What better way to back this up?
Well, we've plotted all
of our top-grossing titles
on the chart that you see
on your left and right.
On the x-axis we can see
the percentage of revenue
from the top 5% of
buyers, which means
the more you're leaning
toward your right,
the more you're
dependent on your revenue
from your top HVUs.
On the y-axis we see the
buyer reactivation rate,
which is essentially how likely
your players will come back
after they're already turned.
You can see an overall
negative correlation here,
which means that the more you're
squeezing out of your buyers,
the more they are less likely
able to come back after they've
already turned from the game.
So we have a really
nice little sweet spot
marked by the yellow star,
where it follows the philosophy
that you would rather have
everyone spend $1 in your game
than to depend on
that one person
who is going to spend $100.
So where can you start?
We would like to
encourage you to challenge
the conventional
thinking that we have.
On this graph we can see
that essentially the lower
the engagement, lower
skill needed from players,
you're more or less
likely going to be
expecting an ads-only game.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
if you are expecting higher
engagement and higher skill,
you're more or less
likely expecting an IAP
and subscription-based game.
What is important
is to challenge
this overall
conventional thinking
that the genre of your
game should necessarily
determine your monetization
strategy in order
to evolve your game economy
with evolution of games today.
So, just like the
evolving game genres,
gamers today have also evolved.
So we're not talking about
the three or four years ago
players who are not
really familiar with one
of the strategies that
are already present.
So therefore, whether you have
a casual or mid-core game,
a singular or a
multi-genre title,
you're still able to
succeed with serving
different monetization
strategies
to this new, mature audience.
So now let's take a look
at how Playgendary does it.
Headquartered in
Germany, Playgendary
is a hyper-casual and
casual game developer
founded in 2016,
with their heart
of development in Belarus.
Starting all the way from the
design stage of their game
development, Playgendary has
always been very experimental
with the way that they
do their in-game revenue
diversification.
We're going to take a
look at the two games
we have right here.
We have Tank Stars, which
is a hyper-casual game,
and we have Partymasters,
which is an idol clicker
and story-based game.
I'll be using these
two titles as examples
of how Playgendary
has challenged
the traditional gaming
revenue strategy.
At the designing
stage of their games
all three monetizations
have already
been considered at the
initial planning stage.
From the start
Playgendary is keen
on combining all
three methods that
are possible in order to strive
for the most optimized results.
Therefore, when looking
at their current titles,
regardless of how the
title actually is,
you'll see different
combinations of rewarded ads,
IAP, and subscriptions.
How do they do this?
To Playgendary, games
is an art form just
like music and just like movies.
Therefore, creating a
great gaming experience
for your partner is their
number one priority and is,
therefore, the most important.
With this in mind they
put their main focus
on adding a lot
of in-game assets
for their players to consume.
The focus of having really good
content and in-depth content,
therefore, leads to a more
stable revenue stream.
How is this content distributed?
We're split into two
different focuses.
One, they are allowing
the game currency
to be distributed and consumed
in any way the player chooses.
So whether you're a
payer or a non-payer,
you're able to
choose how you would
like to experience your game.
And two, gamers loyalty.
We were talking about LTV with
[? Nacho, ?] and therefore
the importance of keeping
your players inside your game
through a lot of live-ops
opportunities and events.
So honing in on game currency.
In Tank Stars, which
is a hyper-casual game,
you can see that all three
methods are used in this title.
How they use it is, IAP--
you're able to buy
different tanks and weapons
and upgrade your in-game assets.
And subscriptions will do
almost exactly the same,
but adding a little
more for the subscriber.
In this game in
particular, actually,
the subscriber revenue takes up
a 46% of the total IAP revenue.
Of course, we can't
forget rewarded ads.
And rewarded ads, although
the players are not
willing to contribute
monetarily directly,
they're still able to
contribute their time.
So what they've done is to
set up a gotcha system where
the player is able to
choose based on gotcha
to see if they can
actually pick out and draw
the tanks that are available
through IAP or subscription.
So in Partymasters, which is a
story-based idol clicker game,
all three monetization
models are also utilized,
and each ties very closely
back to the storyline.
For example, players are able to
help their in-game protagonist
through watching ads for
character accessories
and upgrades, or purchase
gems through IAPs
to purchase similar items.
Or players can get
both needed currencies
through becoming their diamond
members and subscribing.
By focusing on creating a good
storyline for their players,
Playgendary is able to split
their in-game currencies
and content among different
variations of revenue models.
So in terms of
creating gamer loyalty,
Playgendary stresses
the importance of having
a consistent revenue
heartbeat with Live Ops Having
a casual/hyper-casual game did
not rule out the importance
of keeping a really good
lockup system in their game.
As you can see from the graph
that they've shared with us,
Playgendary was able to utilize
one Live Ops event to re-engage
the players who had
installed their games three
to four months ago previously.
How they do this is
split into two types.
So we have the free
holiday content
events that follows
the holiday calendar,
and we have the paid
new mode star available.
For the non-paying buyers,
free Live Ops events
are used to re-engage
the players,
new or old, into letting them
know that the developer still
cares about the player.
So fresh new content
is being pumped
into the game in general just
to create more excitement
for the player.
But even though this
is a free event,
it doesn't rule
out the possibility
of increasing revenue
throughout this Live Ops event.
We can see from
what they've shared
with us that the blue bar
represents all the game packs
that are present regularly.
And the red bars are the
effects of the revenue
through during this
free Live Ops event.
So it's also a good way to
be able to create new paying
buyers.
So, of course, paid
content therefore
is the most direct
way to stimulate
your overall monetization for
your players, new and old.
So this is the method where
you can also create excitement,
but at the same time
create more places
where people are able to
engage and become a new buyer.
Overall the Live Ops account for
40% of their total IAP revenue.
So, as Playgendary has
shown through their games,
having more content
creates more possibility
of adding different
revenue streams.
With the flexibility
of allowing players
to choose how they can
consume in-game content,
as well as creating Live
Ops events to ensure player
engagement and
re-engagement, Playgendary
was able to see
a healthy revenue
stream regardless of the
different genres they have.
Playgendary focus
on gaming experience
and setting up that
in-depth content has also
allowed Playgendary to use
multiple business models that
are complementary but
also substitute-able
for their players
to choose how they
like to experience their game.
And with this I would
like to introduce
my colleague, Moonlit, who
will be sharing with you how
a mid-core game was able to
find success with reward ads.
[APPLAUSE]
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Thank you, Serena.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Moonlit.
I'm a business development
manager at Google Play
Games based in Mountain View.
Today I'll be sharing with
you the story of Kongregate,
how they're able to
boost their revenue
by leveraging ad monetization
across a portfolio.
Kongregate is an indie publisher
based in San Francisco.
They have a portfolio of
games of diverse genres,
ranging from casual to mid-core.
Diversifying their
business model
is the company-wide
strategy, as they
believe it's a
great way to drive
substantial incremental revenue
without much cannibalization.
When we say ad
monetization we think
about casual and hyper-casual.
No wonder, as most of these
games on the market do
rely heavily on ads for revenue.
But what about deeper
mid-core games?
Would ads work for
these genres as well?
Kongregate decided to find out.
Through experimentation
with an open mind,
they found that with
the right design
principles ads actually work
really well for mid-core genre
as well.
Of course, this does
not mean that ads is now
the primary source of revenue.
But, as you will see in
the next few minutes,
the revenue as well
as engagement gain
could be substantial.
Now, before I dive into
the how, in true Google
and Kongregate fashion,
let's look at the data.
Across Kongregate's
portfolio of games
they've seen that ads have
boosted their annual revenue
by 20% to 30%.
And this is without
IAP cannibalization.
Moreover, depending
on the game, ads
can contribute up to 10%
to 70% of total revenue.
So how do they do it?
Two things.
First, Kongregate launched all
new games with ad integration
since Q4 2016.
And two, this
growth is the result
of intentional ad integration
and deliberate ad management.
Now, let's double-click
on the ad revenue.
They found that rewarded
ads has a large market
share on mobile, which is 70%
to 80% of all ads revenue.
Therefore, rewarded ads
is what we'll focus on
in the next case study.
Now, regardless of genre, there
are four design principles when
we implemented rewarded ads.
First, for the ads to be
part of player's habit,
tie the entry points into the
core loop of the game play.
Second, rewards that's
meaningful in how
players progress.
Make sure the rewards also scale
as players advance in-game.
For example, if you only gave
out a fixed amount of currency,
and as players
level up this amount
will quickly become
negligible as players level up
and in-game inflation kicks in.
Third, in terms of
placement the ads
should be accessible
for everyone.
Ideally on the main home
page, but ensure it's
not intrusive or detrimental
to the user experience.
And last, make sure that the
experience itself is also fun.
Inject some humor and
delight by tying it
into the fiction
of the game world.
The case study we'll
look at together
is from Animation Throwdown.
It's a mid-core
card-collecting battler game
that Kongregate launched
in September of 2016.
Together we'll walk through
three different ad units that
have been added in
the game over time,
as well as their
impact in the KPIs.
The first ad unit was
available at launch.
It's a standard ad
unit that provided
better rewards for
all battles played
while the bonus is active.
Let's tie this back
to design principles.
First, the ad unit reinforces
the core game mechanic
of battles.
Second, the reward also scales.
Because it's applied
as a percentage,
thus it remains relevant
regardless of which level
the player is at.
And the third,
this ad design also
encourages repeated
engagement, as players
can stack the bonuses by
watching multiple ads.
The second ad unit was
inspired by the game
Burrito Bison, which is a casual
game in Kongregate's portfolio.
Burrito Bison added an ad
unit that was very successful
called the pinata.
As the name implies,
you reward something
by randomly drop the rewards.
Now, after seeing the great
results from Burrito Bison,
the Animation
Throwdown team also
implemented this
in their own game
by randomly dropping
locked ad crates
as battle rewards, which can
be unlocked by watching an ad.
Now, let's tie this back
to design principles.
First, this ad once again
reinforces the core game
mechanic of battles.
Second, because the
reward is randomized,
it can scale depending on
what level the player is.
The third ad unit was
added more recently.
Now, one of the core game
mechanics in this game
is allowing players
to combine two cards
into a more powerful combo.
But this combo has to first be
discovered through research.
Knowing that players engage with
the research slots every day,
the Animation Throwdown team
added a third research slot
that is only
activated through ads.
They also set clear expectation
that, to activate the research
timer, players will
have to tap a button
to start watching an ad.
Now, tie this back to
the design principles.
First, once again, this
reinforces the core game
mechanic of tech improvement.
Second, in terms of placement,
the ad research slot
is prominently placed next
to the other research slots.
But again, the user initiates
the ad-viewing experience.
Now, let's look at
the KPIs and impact.
The two most important
metrics for rewarded ads
is, first, the number of ads
viewed per player per day.
As you can see on this graph
here, from the original reward
bonus--
which is the blue bar--
to adding the second ad
crate-- the green bar--
they were able to increase
the number of ads viewed
per player per day to
the target of seven
and remain stable since.
But you might be
wondering, why didn't it
grow more with a third ad unit
added, which is the research
[? slot in ?] the yellow bars.
Kongregate told me that
it's actually very important
to keep this metric
steady and balanced,
as to not overwhelm the players.
Therefore, they designed
the ad experience such
that the reward and
benefits is optimized
when players watch between
six and eight ads per day.
The second important
metric is ad engagement.
Well, how many players watched
ads as a percentage of DAU?
This is the metric to
maximize within each game.
Strong engagement counts on
diversifying the ad units, thus
to increase the percentage
of players engaging.
And this is why Kongregate
designed three ad units that
were just covered earlier.
Looking at this graph you
see that adding two more ad
units increased the
ad engagement number
to 60%, which is their target.
Even though Animation
Throwdown is a mid-core game,
this number is actually on
par with other casual games.
Now, if you're thinking about
diversifying your business
model with rewarded ads
or in-game subscriptions,
I have some exciting updates to
share with you from our product
team.
I'll share new features
in two categories,
three will help you find
new buyers, and three more
to help you retain them.
Now, some of these
features are only available
through close beta
right now, so feel
free to take a picture of the
slides when there are links
to the early access
into forums available,
or you can stay in touch by
following the Google Play
newsletter.
First, a feature that'll
help you find new buyers.
Google Play has
partnered with AdMob
to make it even easier
for game developers
like you to integrate
rewarded ads in your games.
Introducing the
rewarded product,
which is Google Play's
offering of rewarded ads.
You can try it in your games
without any additional SDK
integration.
You can find it on your
Play console today.
It is not available.
It is open beta.
Now, for those of you who
are already using AdMob,
this remains to be the most
fully-featured way offered
by Google to integrate
rewarded ads in your game.
More on this after this session.
The second new feature
around new buyer acquisition
is about subscriptions.
This feature is available
in closed beta right now,
and that's the link.
Subscribe, then install.
It's a new feature we're testing
that will allow your players
to subscribe directly in
your Play Store listing page
while the game
gets auto-installed
in the background.
The third and the latest and
greatest of new subscription
feature is allowing
your future buyer
to start their subscription
by directly redeeming
a gift card or a promo code.
This feature is also
available through closed beta.
Now, onto new features that
will help you retain buyers
by reducing voluntary
cancellation.
First, in the cancellation flow,
we now allow players to pause
is an alternative to canceling.
As you can see here that
players have the option
to pause for one,
two, or three months.
Pause will be publicly
available in a few months.
Now, if they still
decide to cancel,
this might be a good time to
create a win-back offer that
will let your players
continue their subscription
at a discount.
This feature is
available in closed beta.
Last, if they still
decide to cancel,
understanding why it's a
good win-back strategy.
Last year we launched
a cancellation survey
to provide you with
the insights of why
your subscribers are leaving.
We found that 74% of users chose
to respond, with 10% of them
actually give a
free formed answer.
The survey results are
available through API query now,
and these insights will be added
to your Play Consoles soon.
Now, I should think about the
takeaways for this session.
I have three wishes for you.
First, I hope you
found the inspiration
to reinvent your
monetization strategy.
Second, I hope you believe
now that your past doesn't
necessarily dictate your future.
And last, I hope you will
all go back to your teams
and ask, how can
we diversify more?
I am excited to see
how you will innovate
and defy conventional thinking.
Would it be through business
model diversification,
regardless of genre,
or maybe more?
Thank you, everyone.
Next I'd like to introduce
Duke, director of product
from AdMob to go deeper on that.
[APPLAUSE]
DUKE DUKELLIS: It's amazing
to see the science and the art
going into rewarded ads, and
I think about the journey
that we've been through.
So I need to do a
statistical question.
How many of you are fans--
like, raging fans-- of ads?
I'm seeing 80%, 90%.
I'm seeing 110%.
OK.
It's amazing.
Remarkable.
So I am Duke.
I lead mobile app
monetization for the ads.
It's been quite an
amazing period of time.
So for those of you who
didn't put your hands up,
we're going to talk through
a couple pro tips here.
I'm going to see how
many hearts and minds I
can shift to embracing it.
And the truth is, when
done right it can actually
improve some experiences,
which is something
that we're pretty
amazed to find that.
You saw some of those
experiences come before,
and really it's
around psychology.
Today I'm going to
talk about three tips
that are very focused on this
evolution of the industry
and what we're seeing out there.
And at the end we're
going to check back.
We'll do another
statistical sample here
and see if we
shifted that from 80%
to the rest of the 100% of you.
All right.
So first tip is about building
this into game design.
You saw some of that in
the sessions we just had.
And if you do this right you can
actually make users feel good.
They're getting something.
They're earning something
extra that they otherwise
felt like they could
not have gotten.
And that's terrific.
But you could also
build revenue streams.
Now, we saw all this happening.
It's been going.
You saw the experiences.
So we put our heads
together and we really
thought about how can we
make this easier for you.
And right now we have a huge
base on AdMob and Ad Manager,
and we said, well, for
those of you not on there,
what can we do to get this into
your hands as fast as possible?
And we're just watching
this chart grow and we said,
who else can we reach out to?
And there's a whole
segment of developers who
really have been IAP focused.
And I think back
two years ago where
a lot of those discussions were
really, don't touch the app.
IAP is everything.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit more about this.
This has shifted remarkably
in the last two years.
I mean, this has been
really remarkable.
So the first step we've
taken-- and you just
heard this before-- was
getting rewarded ads in play.
So this means if
you're already offering
IAP you can do it very quickly.
So I'm going to show you--
here's a screenshot
of the Play console.
And you'll notice the
tab over on the right.
So there are these
rewarded products.
And one of those rewarded
products is rewarded ads.
So this is as simple as,
instead of choosing an IAP price
you choose an ad.
An ad is the cost.
That's the cost that
the user is paying here.
And it's that simple.
So that's awfully darn easy.
We're really excited to
see how this is going.
We've been running it
through some beta programs
and now we're announcing
the open beta right now.
OK.
Let's move on.
Number two.
So, supplementing
IAP revenue with ads.
So what we're seeing
is, developers
who use this combination--
yes, the numbers are all
going in the right direction.
You add ads-- and
again, this is a shift
of thinking from just IAP or
just ads to go, how can we
put these two things together?
And rewarded ads, again, is one
of these areas where it just
changes the mold.
And if you think
about-- initially it
was about banners or
native, find the space,
and interstitials.
You put them between, and
rewarded has really just
been something different
because it's that opt-in.
It's that I choose
to do something.
I choose to do this.
So here's Cookie Jam.
It's just a really
terrific developer.
And they've really put
these two things together.
They put these boosters in.
And over the over long-term--
so here's the remarkable part.
They're using the free
rewarded experience
to drive an experience
that then people say,
I like that experience
so much I'm actually
willing to pay for it.
OK?
So they're seeing an uplift
in IAP with rewarded ads
being the trial way in.
And they're also seeing
the users who never would
have made any money for them.
Which, by the way, in
most of these games
tends to be an awful
lot of those users.
They're watching
rewarded ads which
means they're generating
advertising revenue.
So this is where--
this breaks the mold.
Like, this is not a
pure, oh, show ads,
user experience declines.
That's not necessarily
what's happening here.
In fact, we're seeing a drive
towards better monetization.
And that's just really
terrific to see.
OK.
So let's move on to
tip number three.
So non-spending players.
So this has been the
really interesting piece.
And I'll go back--
two years ago I was talking to a
number of different publishers,
developers around, hey, we know
you make a lot of money on IAP,
but really how much?
And we heard things
from 1%, 3%, 5%, 10%.
That's the number
of users in my base,
or the percentage
where I'm making money.
It turns out the rest--
so sometimes that's
80%, 90%, more--
are not making money.
That's a net cost for your
app, for your service,
if you're on a server.
They're sort of costing money.
In some places that makes sense
because of networks and such.
But in many cases they're
sitting there going,
I really want to
monetize that group,
but I want to take no chances
on this other group of users
who are paying me money.
I just can't afford to
take the risk there.
So again, we went to
work here and we thought,
how can we do this?
So what if there was a
way to segment out smartly
the users who are going to
spend and don't show them
this ads experience from the
users who are almost certainly
not going to purchase?
And those users we want to go
ahead and put the personalized
ad profile, and that's how
we'll make money off of them.
And it's that simple.
So here's an example.
You've got the game on the
left in mission overview.
And we segment this, we look.
We use our machine
learning to figure out
what's going on here.
Who's the spender?
OK.
They follow the
path up at the top.
Who's not the spender?
Unlikely to make a
purchase, very unlikely
to make a purchase.
We send them through, we
give them ad experience.
so we've tailored this to
the profile of the consumer
and how they prefer to
help pay for the app.
So this is pretty big
news because now we're
taking a risk-free approach
to generate more revenue here.
So, it's a first step.
It's really easy to do this.
When you go create an
interstitial ad unit
right now--
this is what we've
announced we're launching--
there's a box that says,
smart segmentation.
It's that simple.
And then what we do is
we go ahead and look.
We use our machines
to go figure out who
are the spenders, the
likely spenders, who
are the unlikely
spenders, and then
we just start doing this
for you automatically.
It's as simple as a checkbox.
OK?
And we've seen-- yeah.
Here's an example.
We've seen 30% increase
on ads revenue site
because they've been introducing
ad units that they before
were afraid to introduce because
it might have impacts on IAP.
So that's what I've got.
They're pretty
quick and tactical,
but can make a huge difference.
And I actually find these
things just so revolutionary to
where we were one
year, two years ago.
So, number one was,
really think about how
this rewarded fits into the
game and the psychology.
You heard that through
the sessions before.
You can go to the
rewarded play option
and you can get that design
and placement up, like,
immediately.
You can test out
what things work,
what things don't work
without a lot of integration.
Number two, you can
supplement that IAP revenue
with the rewarded and
probably grow your IAP
if you do this right.
And then number three,
our smart segmentation
offering-- now it's a checkbox.
It's that simple.
Don't put any of
your IAP at risk.
And you have a
chance to monetize
90% plus of your users
who aren't spending.
So it's a real win.
So, that said, I need to do
another statistical sample
here.
Show of hands, who now
is a raging fan of ads?
OK.
Yes?
This is overwhelming.
I feel the love.
This is great.
[INAUDIBLE] I think
it just comes in
to really talk about how
successful this whole area has
been.
And the more we can put these
tools and these products
in your hands to make
money, just the happier
it really makes the team here.
So thank you all for that.